HANK: So… Physics. Uh, right. Physics, physics,
physics, physics…are you getting all this?
We have been talking about doing Crash Course
Physics for a long, long, longlonglong time.
You’ve wanted it, we’ve wanted to do it, and now thanks to our friends at PBS Digital Studios, we’re doing it.
There’s just one thing.
I’m hosting Crash Course Philosophy.
But I do know someone super-qualified for the job.
SHINI: Hi!
HANK: Hi. This is our host for Crash Course
Physics.
Me? I’m gonna go have a corndog and host
Philosophy. Take it away, Shini!
SHINI: I’m Dr. Shini Somara, a mechanical
engineer and fluid dynamicist by qualification.
For the last few years I've been hosting
science and  tech shows on TV,
like TechKnow, Tomorrow's Food,
and The Health Show.
Wanna know more about me?
There are links in the dooblydoo.
So... let’s talk Physics! I love physics and chances
are you do too, even if you don’t know it yet.
So I’m really excited to host this
series of Crash Course. In this series, we’ll
be covering AP Physics 1 & 2, mostly. But we’ll also
have a little time for other things along the way.
Everything you do, build, or say will be governed
by physics, so wouldn’t it be nice to read
the rule book? A rule book that will help
you through life. Physics is elegant.
It’s also practical and fun. Understanding
time, position, velocity, and acceleration
and how they all work together can help you
understand your place in the universe -- literally!
And I’m sure you’ve heard of Newton’s
Laws, like his first law: An object in motion
will remain in motion, and an object at rest
will remain at rest, unless acted upon by a force.
But what does that mean?
And what does it have to do with acceleration?
And what are vectors? Scalars?
And what does this mean?
Kinetic Friction and Static Friction?
What’s the difference?
We’ll explain all of that. But what’s
more special is getting to figure out why
understanding these things is so valuable.
Understanding how the world, the universe,
works gives us a richer and more immersive
experience in life. It gives us the opportunity
to see the beauty in nature in vast and unexpected
ways.
Now a lot of people think physics is hard,
but it's easy!
Well, it’s as easy as we can make it.
So join me, Dr. Shini Somara, this year on
Crash Course Physics which is produced in
association with our good friends at PBS Digital
Studios.